today on our show get out your boners
because we can be talking about Game of
Thrones that's right we're gonna do the
entire Game of Thrones season of thus
far today on fat keV and a little mark
[Laughter]
that men on Batman wasn't Batman I'm
Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm open all
right kids
Game of Thrones what season is this this
is seven you're watching it loving
you're all caught up
yes spoilers if you haven't watched Game
of Thrones this season thus far any of
those before episode tortoises [ __ ] off
because we're going to talk about
dragons and [ __ ] and Dragons red things
popping out all the [ __ ] we've seen so
far
poison dirty dragon [ __ ] we are going to
talk Game of Thrones we're going to
spoil the [ __ ] out of it so if you
haven't seen it yet this season turn it
off go watch something else go watch one
of our other videos where we don't talk
about Game of Thrones but right now
we're discussing the Iron Throne tricot
chuck is five four three two one
holy [ __ ] that's holy [ __ ] let's do the
episode one set the table context well
remind me what happened in Episode one
it takes pieces i watch it on my phone
all the time man let's see here's how I
feel like episode one was Danny getting
to Dragonstone right let's add a shot
Dragonstone yeah and let's see what
their description is oh [ __ ] don't turn
zone wanted the great game is terrifying
um it what can't do him not at all start
yes first episode was Dragonstone right
the big moment was Daenerys getting to
Westeros my ancestral home of
Dragonstone
we have Targaryen is ruled for centuries
yes
touching ground and last time we saw
that place was with Stannis Baratheon
here at Castle to plan his war for a nut
[ __ ] went well for him apparently
Dragonstone is awesome luck for people
launching sieges onto Westeros and thus
far the season Danny hasn't had much
luck at all and having found the color
commentator
has she horse has she well I'll tell you
keV it's been going pretty poorly for
Daenerys Targaryen and grow through
if only that scorpion hadn't shot an
arrow it was a drag oh yeah
Drogo drogon [ __ ] man Lee tell you
something here's my quick game of
Thrones story so that's episode the one
that just happens full
sweet full spoils of war I was just
telling these cats before we started I
was in England the land of Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones land and then I
went to France as well then before I
left France I paid an exorbitant amount
on [ __ ] francs
oh my god dude like I took that a
governor on my phone you go overseas use
your cell phone use data whatever
[ __ ] a lot of money [ __ ] so you can
hook up through like you know a Wi-Fi
system or something like that but if you
do that you can't watch your programs
from back home you got to be on a VPN or
something so I just used you know you
know the 4G network and blew through all
my [ __ ] time cost you $700 to watch
an episode literally was that's that is
the talking net dude I called them up I
was like I can't watch Game of Thrones
man though like he went over all your
data and I was like I a grown-ass man
don't tell me that like I can pay my
bills
give me my data back and I like will
take the governor off but we just want
you to know like it's gonna go like
crazy and like you know it'll shut down
again at the next thousand dollar mark
and I was like well I won't hit there
750 bucks only to watch Game of Thrones
and in [ __ ] Europe you know what it
was worth it
god damn worth it I know I've lost
perspective and [ __ ] like that yet
little boy made clerks has forgotten
what money is and what it's worth but I
love the show man it's been fifteen
thousand months on HBO I haven't put in
$50 a day just to watch it in Europe
episode crazy so I watched it in France
for we took off and then we took off and
I lost Wi-Fi signal and there was no
Wi-Fi no [ __ ] no Wi-Fi going across
even if there was I wouldn't be able to
watch HBO go so for the eight-hour
flight I watched 30 minutes of the show
the last ten minutes that happened I'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on hold
flight across the Atlantic I was sitting
there like can I get you something I'm
like [ __ ] HBO can you get back to
drink mr. Smith yeah bragging dragon's
meat or whatever [ __ ]
so when we landed in Los Angeles like
soon as I got off the plane I [ __ ]
hooked my [ __ ] up and I was waiting for
the bag just watching going yes yes but
no don't shoot the dragon real tight so
it's I mean that last episode the the
last 25 minutes yes is unbelievable for
any number of reasons I mean a they
spent all of the money it was called the
spoils of war rose of war the Battle of
the bastards which was last season's
yeah giant [ __ ] combat Palooza was
impressed was impressive they spent 30
days shooting just that fight team last
year but they spent about the same just
showing the loot rain during the
literature the loot rain what they
called the loot train raid and and it's
an amazing sequence not just because of
the the choreography and the logistics
of it but they found a way to give you
to put you in the middle of a battle
scene where you're rooting for both
sides I know that was astounding dude I
was sitting there gone like [ __ ] I
don't want anybody shooting the dragon I
want the dragon to [ __ ] burn who is
ever trying to shoot him but I love sir
Bronn of the Blackwater Brown of the
black oh my god he's not me in the show
but he's the common man he's my way into
that go and [ __ ] like that I've always
loved them your name stick on new who
has so then all you're sitting there
throughout the whole battle like you
said you're gone oh man I don't know who
I want to win here I hope nobody [ __ ]
die yeah like Jamie started the show
started series as a villain we push the
boy out of window that's been so dhwani
purpose a little boy out the window we
could [ __ ] his sister it's like clearly
the bad guy understandable
understandable as we've all felt in our
lives don't have a sister I'm cool he
should be a [ __ ] bad guy but he
should be and they built him as a bad
guy but over the course of those seasons
they've cut off his hand they brought
him load him into a prison I didn't even
do it for me he just at the end of it
all he pretty much he has a good heart
yes he [ __ ] his sister which doesn't
mean he's got a bad heart it means
though maybe he needs the you know
[ __ ] stern talking-to
but the the you know the that aspect of
them doesn't make him a bad guy
Kingslayer we understand he did that to
save the kingdom yeah so I can't really
dislike him to that the only thing
still got against him is that he pushed
bran out the window and episode one but
based on current brand we should have
pushed him out the window again
Iran has become the female Oh [ __ ] III
I'd rave and he's just like nothing
matters everything is gone
yes isn't that well that was awesome
death for you cuz he was quoting my
[ __ ] back to him like a little finger
went cold and [ __ ] that's because little
finger had like couple seasons back he
was telling people like chaos is a
ladder you know Oliver views we can go
nuts you use it to climb up and [ __ ] so
when he said chaos is a lotta chaos is a
ladder and then Littlefinger went all
[ __ ] like [ __ ] Littlefinger that that
was cool tie in but other than that
[ __ ] emo brand man I like likes to
sit around the sisters and be like you
look so nice give your white wedding
dress that night I watched you get raped
like being the why right I'll see you
later brand
enjoy the train with I'm going inside I
kind of like him now because he reminds
me a little bit of Paul Atreides of maja
Deeb oh when he went [ __ ] again after
he [ __ ] takes to water my water every
blue eyes I was spending like a reed in
the wind you know like the I've seen it
all I've done and I live now I've
transcended and I'm now being beyond
space and time look like his Jesus in
the temple moment where you know he's
like didn't you know I had to do my
father's work and Mary's like your
father just guys not even your father is
it buddy with the father totally like
yeah who is the [ __ ] father so yes I
guess there was a bit of that but still
I prefer I prefer brand before he became
the 300 but I'm not saying bad idea I'm
glad it's happening but you know yeah it
seems like he'd be easier to be around
before he was the three-eyed Raven now
everything's [ __ ] darkness I just
like that this was the Eggman in the
minimun mm in a minute you could see him
quietly moshing alone picked a teen
dance club in the 80s listen to Judas
Priest while the one else is listening
to the roof roof he's got a Walkman
listen in Judas Priest [ __ ] I just like
this this is also the episode where we
get to see it registers how much
when they start kids have paid to get
where they are yes
you know like bran is basically just
sort of bronze reminding people what
happened to you what happened to you so
I got my [ __ ] some of that I was in
and you know I remember it's weird that
you do yeah that is true man like you
spend one shot of Arya showing up and
seeing Winterfell men running into the
James on a bobble at the front gate
you're like [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] you I
do is my arrow name tell me how you
[ __ ] do it
punch you right in the [ __ ] face I
was like more of them that [ __ ]
winds up in the iron right now you know
throws weight around my name is Clive
and I'm the king of the Seven Kingdoms
look [ __ ] off little girl so she's a
killer
oh [ __ ] that means like she and Lady
Brienne Brienne of Tarth
fightin sack that's fighting it didn't
mean journey off is like when they're
doing this [ __ ] you saw all of the
styles that she has grown up not just
like you know being what do they call
faceless wasn't it yeah being taught
there in the house and black and white
black and white you also saw a bit of
the water dancer you know the first guy
hello Florio is like one of my favorite
characters shown they iced him like
right away what should we say to death
not today today run child and you're
like this my [ __ ] go [ __ ] everyone up
with a wooden stick and then he did
until I go hide away but then later on
the hill the main character like oh [ __ ]
all right because I was doing that so
yes
watching her fight Brienne and watching
her like like pull the dagger like be
[ __ ] a smile helling year-to-year
that was really special
now that dagger we know it has
historical significance because
Littlefinger was [ __ ] like amens the
daggers almost used to kill you and [ __ ]
and there's a bit of a mystery as to
like wet the DECA come from allegra
where do you think do you think it has
well number one that daggers in are his
hands now right there's no way LuAnn
still there's no way dad when the
[ __ ] are not losing their heads
they're not yeah come on walkers are
going to fall under that blade and you
know if you're going to give it to
anybody give it to her cause clock she
can do some nice quick bit of business I
mean how awesome is it going to
eventually be when the White Walkers
show up at Winterfell and it's like aria
and or a little
Aria and herd and a little sticker and
needle to and like a Boogaloo oh very
good yes Aria seeing Winterfell was
teradata ticket sanso being in charge of
Winterfell yes and I've you know I
watched the after the game of Thrones
room two dudes are always like talking
all serious about inches I love that
it's like my poor and I'm like yeah man
yeah like it really [ __ ] ties a deep
and it's like we're talking about show
bed dragon good so so they talked about
like last time these two were together
you know this one is like I want to
fight I won't fight when she was little
I want to get married and the other one
yeah wanted to be a lady and they both
got what they wanted like that [ __ ]
taxi song goodbye what's his name well
[ __ ] like me I'm flying in my taxi
getting tips and getting stoned whatever
[ __ ] memories she was wanted to be an
actress
Wow as I learned to fly she set off to
Sun the footlights I said off to fan was
Harry Chapin Harry Chiba there it is had
to them they both got what they wanted
she became but way more than they ever
imagined [ __ ] hell she became a
[ __ ] killer and she became the queen
of Winterfell don't say it is Winterfell
so unless she's not married to John wood
so with John's if John gets married one
day would she be the queen of Winterfell
well I mean where if I would have a
queen what if I only have a lady there
goes Louisa King in the north he's a
king in the north but not the king of
Winterfell good point
so would there be a queen in the north
if he gets married if he does there
would be he had one for a minute right
before the red wedding when they're like
yes right down there I should have
stopped watching this bucket show any
show that stabs a pregnant woman in the
belly he's just up to no good
although the Han oh man it's just I get
yourself no good right us watching Aria
kill every [ __ ] fray left yeah all
the phrase yeah well game on I'd yeah
she's like eat your boys where's my son
my worthless son ate your son but now is
thinking about a bad actor yeah it was
badass and then they did a [ __ ] cool
callback to it with my man hot pie well
I believe will one
up on the inside he's a survivor as we
told you know me Aria I are I'm a
survivor and you're a wizard and he he
says like sheep he finally was like you
look good as a girl we can't believe I
thought you a boy but anyway all hot pie
was talking about how to brown the
butter when you're making a cake or make
it a pie and that sounds way dirtier
than I think it should bran the better
around that butter sob and she was just
like I didn't do that and she's like you
made it you're making pies she's like
Jackie a chubby favorite part I'll show
she's love Aria I love when she kills
[ __ ] and puts it in the pie
yeah we got to see Walder Frey it was at
the opening of that song on episode 202
got seawater frame eat his [ __ ]
referential and we got to see Lady
Ileana
the Tyrell of High God I Anna Anna rig
every tie on a rig yeah what a [ __ ] I
mean she was a major player like last
season this season yes she a part of you
like in account later tyrella yes Tyrell
what's her name lady Ola olena Ilona but
[ __ ] did they let her go I mean she was
the big casualty thus far shucky we're
talking about [ __ ] Thrones Highgarden
um yeah man [ __ ] she lost board
Margaery mm-hmm and her brother
last season [ __ ] iron fist I shoe off
yeah it's cheated Raven and and then you
know she was helping Danny plan the war
and [ __ ] like that
but she got Jamie kind of smoked him out
yeah and she was the only one who ever
gave to any good advice really at the
end of the day yeah well I was just like
you were away from dragons yeah be a
dragon yeah that's true
Poosh and she said she was like you know
your man who gives good advice but you
know no man every man who's ever given
me advice is dead like that but then
then Jamie comes and storms our castle
yeah while the unsullied think they're
taking Casterly Rock
they [ __ ] you know did a
bait-and-switch and they went and
[ __ ] killed the old lady soldiers and
took over high guard and took all their
money and her money to all the loot
that's in the loot train and [ __ ] and so
they could pay back the iron bank
the Lannisters Oh always pay their debts
if it means cutting throats and [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes so Jamie gets to like sit down
and tell Lady Olenna Lee and Tyrell sure
dinah rig that uh hey man was there the
queen of Thrones or something yeah
screen of doors Emma Peel we'll just
call him okay and stay give her the swan
song scene man where she down system
drinks the boys and then she gets to
like just [ __ ] tell Jamie to his face
I killed your boy will this poison hurt
unlike your son she's like good because
your son died horribly yeah I was - yeah
I was hoping that it would be I didn't
know he would turn purple purple was a
nice bonus didn't you think he was going
to be like ah ah just hack earn - yeah
kept his hand man you only got one well
um
that's what state is and it was gold
yeah man like that's but that's another
reason I think Jamie's a good guy
because anyone else he was true [ __ ]
he'll she gets through half that little
[ __ ] speech yet or even finishes it
and he just [ __ ] guts okay with roan
slow but you know he didn't I think he's
got a good heart he's decent man but
he's in love with the wrong [ __ ]
person I mean not just on the whole like
biological look we were related but
Jesus what else she's what I hateful
harpy this woman is Cersei is on fire
this season man and she she seems to be
winning the game of Thrones if you will
thus far although last episode tides
turn as Danny was like practice I got a
dragon mom she never ending story did
popping up into the field with her luck
dragon star [ __ ] taking [ __ ] out that
room wasn't an amazing dude [ __ ] just
a breathtaking shots with dragon like
everyone's reaction Jaime Lannister's
reaction him and bran with a [ __ ]
looking like it's so awesome like
everybody else for the Game of Thrones
world gets to now see the Dragons you
get to see their reactions to the
Dragons and you still feel kind of the
same way when you see a dragon like I
still takes my breath away my call and
I've never been a swords and sorcery
kind of guy like comic books and [ __ ]
like that and so I find fantasy but like
I was doing line I like [ __ ]
works and swords and [ __ ] that was
always that guy now you liked it you
know cheaper you know what it's like D&D
I played the Indian High School's in the
first books I read were Conan the
Barbarian books but I loved Cohan yeah
there were dragons and [ __ ] in there
I'll be honest he's just [ __ ] Lord of
the Rings is real tough god those movies
are long it felt like watching the Bible
like did you know everyone had thousand
names everyone was Holies [ __ ] um took
my wife to go see Fellowship of the Ring
and she didn't know it was a trilogy and
so we get to the end she's like are they
still [ __ ] walking oh yeah [ __ ]
all they're gonna choose she would drop
the mic and broken a door off and
flipped a table if there was one in the
theater those movies we had those Lord
of the Rings movies back in the 80s mark
we just called it a robo sighs for
people a [ __ ] exercise I thought I do
miss movies exercise then they sit and
talk in the next a little more you would
think I'd love to talking parts but like
not so much and again I'm not saying
like these movies are a brilliant
craftsmanship Peter Jackson is a [ __ ]
fantastic genius and deserves every
plaudit he ever got but that this happen
really popped my cork at all this [ __ ]
not only pops my courgette tops it off
and keeps [ __ ] jerking me off after
I've nut it and I'm like stop at no like
no way no joke artists never come twice
in a [ __ ] row before I let it go my
party so hostile right to be hostile
difficult it is it has spent spell
bonding yeah that episode and we are
just for em dude yeah how many more left
in the sea three three in this season
and then there's a final season to come
well season how long do we have to wait
for that final seasons I know a man
years I should just love the one I'm
with which is the currency instead of
worrying about what happens next it's
gonna be a negative agree more to go
first episode Dragonstone wonderful but
slow nothing really going on when we get
to Stormborn that's the one where Theon
and and y'all are actually gets attacked
by your arm what a prick there's a new
Ramsey right move they need a prick they
need a heal but to be fair he's a
charming prick and I bumped
into him at the London Film comic-con me
and Marco at the London Film comic-con
is so much fun had a blast did Batman
Batman there I saw the dude played
you're on pretty sure it's him hmm and
then somebody said you're onto you and I
was like I can't think I saw him in
hallway it was his wife and his kid and
his kid was like you know upset she
wants to go outside and I waved at her
and he goes too many old she's seen that
she was adorable well yeah and that
[ __ ] show you know what a prick he
shows up like the [ __ ] goblin king of
Westeros Halloween and gets in Jamie's
face and asks for how-to advice on how
to have sex with the system cuz you're
like a finger in the bum oh my god
so shows off the chain so this season as
far as then [ __ ] yes I'm on board I
mean I have been for seven years but I
know uh Queen's Justice episode will
happen around as we're this sand snakes
like she kisses the daughter and she's
like you're gonna watch her rot in this
Jail and then she goes and like [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of her brother and then the
next morning like there's a knock at the
door he's like we can't be seen together
comes like [ __ ] Queen just [ __ ] it
all and then she Hanson's door and the
[ __ ] person at the door like she's
Jamie and her and does the mental man
and [ __ ] and she's just like you got a
meeting and she's like whatever bring me
fresh sheets
I just [ __ ] mess with my brother like
that was insane didn't say that exactly
but that was the implication [ __ ] and we
got surged hora por ser jorah being
healed by [ __ ] uh by Samwell Tarly
look at yes yeah and I like the addition
of what's his name brother yes who's
been wonderful wonderful yeah what
healings to Jorah and Daenerys told him
I command you to heal yourself and she
was crying he's gonna come back and be
like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] get it and now
she's got to take him back she can't be
like well he's tried to kill me and [ __ ]
like not he loves her all of the love he
loves her he needs to be there he'll
give his life for I guarantee he will
die at somebody's hand to save Daenerys
but now there's going to be like nine
people in love with Daenerys way more
Tyrians in love with her [ __ ] John
I'm not in love it's more like you give
it a beautiful speech last season like
when she made it right before she made
him the hand where she was like I don't
believe in anything but I do believe in
here right like it's not romantic love
yeah it's absolute devotion yes and Jon
Snow said yeah I think she's got a good
heart I've seen you look at it a good
hard yeah do you think they get together
fire night I mean that's what I'm in the
minima miminum
that's what the show is pointing us
which is why I don't think it happened
everybody [ __ ] in the show why not them
oh yeah well I thought they were related
in some weird yeah she is his aunt but
that is odd people in this room know who
insist is never a barrier romance it is
it's a fantastic season what are the
dudes names Benioff and white yes Dan
licen now DB Weiss and David Benioff one
of them's married to Amanda Peet even
the other one I don't know he's married
that's [ __ ] two huge wins in life too
you get to make a game of Thrones mm-hmm
and you're married to Amanda Peet like
from here you should just retire from
the field without you should have two
[ __ ] things
hey is one thing buddy now I'm not sure
the [ __ ] will keep doing both that
sounded dirtier than my I [ __ ] love
this show it's fantastic and we're not
alone I'm not we're not converting now
to here
have you never seen Game of Thrones yeah
check it out maybe you should call it
shot dragons there it is man [ __ ] Game
of Thrones current season we'll check
back in after the last three of them yes
I'm sure
until then that's all we got this week
on Batman on Batman tune in next week
and until then for fat man Batman I'm
Kevin Smith I am the god of kicks in
line wow you and look for him at the God
of kitchen twine Bernard is 38 because
there's 37 more in from him I mean it's
a cue ah tune in same fat time same fat
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
you
[Music]